all right so Enola Holmes is out now
meaning that another mystery is afoot so
Tip Top Cheerio grab your tea and
scrumpets because a crime is to be
solved but in this video we're going to
be discussing that ending some of the
film's real life counterparts are
theories for potential sequels or
spin-offs along with our reaction and
review for the second Millie Bobby Brown
joint now if you enjoy this video then
whack that like button as it helps the
channel and allows us to afford even
more jaffy Dodges and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day if this is your first time here I'm
Jared welcome to the heavy spoiler show
now let's get into Enola homes too
thank you
[Music]
so this sequel takes place roughly a
year after the first with Enola having
opened her own detective agency that's
doing about as well as elon's Twitter
takeover zero clients because of her age
and gender with many asking for the real
Sherlock not this strange girl who looks
like she's 11. though a young girl named
Bessie swoops in with a missing person's
case that saves anola's livelihood and
the movie's plot essentially Bessie's
Sister Sarah they're they're not real
sisters one morning just turned up
missing what okay back up how the hell
do you turn up Mississippi because
nobody knows where you are when they
realize you ain't there the initial
Clues are Sarah's red hair her being an
academic lipstick and one wilting plant
while another is flourishing this leads
anola to the Lions match Factory where
she not only discovers Sarah had stolen
important Ledger documents from the
Lion's Office but a sickness called
typhus is spreading like an epidemic
with many of the factory girls
Contracting it this feels eerily similar
to uh never mind Enola spies on a
meeting between Mr lion his cub William
along with Mr McIntyre and his secretary
Miz Mira Troy enola's hunched to follow
Sarah's flatmate May proves fruitful as
she discovers that they work together at
the Paragon Theater as performers rather
than the Stag antlers bar that she had
told Bessie that she works at something
is amiss as Enola gathers more evidence
including matching lipstick and a hidden
Love Letter feeling a shadow follow her
Enola bumps into a drunken Sherlock as
both head back to his place the plot
thickens as Sherlock's own Mystery which
looks like a Charlie Kelly Pepe Silvia
situation may have a connection with
enolas both involving Financial dealings
and Bank transfers and Nola's
unintentional intentional meeting with
Tewksbury the Young lad from the first
film in the park furthers this
investigation as she cracks The Love
Letter Cipher and identifying that the
flower drawing in the letter is a poppy
leading her to 28 Belle Place White
Chapel no no no no not a church instead
quite a love nest with a dead may wait
May's dead already things are a bit
fishy though because inspector lestrade
a few police officers and superintendent
Grail arrive minutes later who is most
certainly The cane-wielding Stranger
stalking A nola the night before
obviously caught red-handed uh anola has
red blood on her whatever anola is
obviously suspect number one in May's
death learning that both Enola and Grail
have a shared interest in finding Sarah
anola escapes before she can be arrested
now knowing she is looking for a gent
with a tapered hat of which was found in
May's crime scene anola then realizes
that the drawing is not that of a poppy
but that of a Sweet William William Lyon
the Gent she saw at the factory it's all
connected man knowing this Enola heads
off to the matchmaker's ball tricking
William into giving up his handwriting
confirming that he in fact wrote the
letter that Sarah was hiding later
questioning him during a dance back to
the Pepe Silvia Sherlock case like
poetry in motion Sherlock realizes that
the banking transfer pattern is that of
the 27 dances that exist there's 27
dances okay the the Cupid Shuffle
Macarena whatever the hell this is okay
okay
um either way he cracks the cipher
revealing a chilling message in an
almost jigsaw wanna play a game fashion
good to meet you Sherlock Holmes with
the account name Bean
Moriarty oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
the game is a foot but uh Nola
unfortunately goes to jail this whole
sequence is honestly unnecessary
[Music]
anola's mother and Edith puthy breaker
out smoke bomb a carriage beat up Grail
in his goons you get it it's it's action
and we're back to London now like the
ending to a Saw movie all of the clues
and pieces finally fall into place
revealing Sarah and may had been doing
their own research discovered the white
phosphorus used for the new matches as
opposed to the old red tips was the
cause of the typhus amongst the factory
girls lions and McIntyre knew of this
but wanted a cheaper product resulting
in huge huge absolutely huge profits
Sarah was to expose them that's why
Grail was hired to arrest her before she
could talk even William Lyon Sarah's
lover was working with them to expose
the truth with the help of T-Bone Enola
and Sherlock seek more answers from
William only to find him dead upon
further investigation though all of the
clues at the scene seemingly are planned
to throw them off but Enola finds a
crumpled piece of sheet music in
William's hand T-Dog informs them the
truth of the gods that Gods can refer to
the top level of the theater the Paragon
Theater this directs back there with X
marking the spot despite Dr Jones's
teachings leading Enola Sherlock and
Teaberry to all of the evidence needed
to expose Lions McIntyre and their
financial Corruptions Sarah reveals
herself having been the blonde Sicily in
a wig at the ball as everything is
gathered to hand over to the authorities
Grail and his goons arrive stating it's
all blackmail none of it's gonna stick
attempting to kill each of them through
this you realize grail's corruption ties
in with the Lions and McIntyre I thought
it was funny that Grail said this I used
to dream I'd end up on this stage only
to have that dream come true when Enola
pecker hooked him crashing down to the
stage as the dust settles Sherlock has
one more trick up his sleeve revealing
that no it was not Grail or even
McIntyre that was behind all of this but
rather Meera Troy AKA
Moriarty she had made a Fateful Error
that led to her identity Troy solely
doing this to get ahead she as a woman
in these times had to make her own way
maybe getting a bit dirty while doing it
completely Sinister as she says it was
fun being taken away as she slyly says
it's a shame all dense had to end but
maybe just maybe we'll take the flow
once again I know that's a bad accent
Just Go With It clearly tying in with
the final newspaper article Sherlock is
reading stating Master criminal escapes
opening the door for the Nola homes 3 or
even a Sherlock Standalone film that
sees him a going wit to wit with this
iconic antagonist if you you didn't know
these two are like Batman and the Joker
of the British crime-solving world uh
that's uh my man explaining for the day
the final minute see anola and Sarah
Chapman leading a Revolt at the match
Factory informing all of the workers of
the deadly phosphorus and typhus Origins
leading to them striking while tea bag I
mean tootsberry uses his political
influence of a lord to charge McIntyre
with the corruption charges he had been
avoiding Enola once again opens her
detective agency while her and
Tewkesbury the Dapper nincompoop happily
strolled down the road surprisingly a
decent portion of this core plot
involving a match company deadly white
phosphorus the workers striking and even
Sarah Chapman is rooted in reality in
July 1888 roughly 1400 women and girls
went on strike from the Bryant and may
match company over low pay and hazardous
working conditions this strike continued
for a handful of weeks resulting in
Bryant and may caving to the demanded
improved working conditions Sarah
Chapman had been one of the leading
forces in the strikes and has since been
remembered via a charitable organization
called the Matchstick girls Memorial
that was developed in 2019 the
organization has raised awareness of the
match girl strike and its participants
while also passing on that Spirit to
today's labor force so not only does
Enola homes 2 have a bit of historical
relevance but also relates to various
working conditions over the last handful
of years with everything that has you
know kind of happened now don't leave
just yet as there's a Marvel
studios-esque mid credit scene setting
up a potential sequel slash spin-off in
this Holmes World Thursday at 4 comes
around with Sherlock at his place on
Baker Street there's a ring at the door
however it is not anola but rather a
strange man asking about the flat mate
situation this is revealed to be Dr John
Watson played by himesh Patel the
longtime partner of Sherlock Holmes in
all of the different interpretations of
Sherlock's mystery solving I actually
love this both Patel playing you know
the character but also setting up either
an Enola homes 3 or Holmes in Watson no
no no no no not that movie Jesus but
these two going off after an escaped
Moriarty or even getting into scrambles
of their own overall anola homes 2 was
was fine it was harmless even but
doesn't do too much to keep you
interested for the final piece of the
puzzle to fall into place I feel like
the biggest problem was the run time
like it's bloated by about 25 minutes
when Enola goes to prison and her mum
blows her out only to wind up back
exactly where she was before it just
seemed a bit perplexing the mystery
solving bits were my favorite a huge
step up from the first you know like the
small details that you may have missed
finally all connecting so tighten it up
pump in some more sure lock mystery
maybe even a cameo from Scooby-Doo I
don't know I'm just making up right now
surprisingly the introduction of Watson
had my fan flailing the most because the
three of them teaming up has some
promise Enola and Sherlock's chemistry
was spot on so bring in Hamish Patel for
that threesome what but yeah I'd be
interested to hear your thoughts on
Enola homes too and if you would like to
see a third or maybe even spin-off with
Holmes and Watson and I'll let you know
we are currently running a competition
right now giving away three copies of
top gun Maverick on the 15th of November
and all you have to do to get a chance
of winning this is like this video make
sure to subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment Down Below on your
thoughts of Enola homes 2. we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of last month are
on screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos whether it be our Andor episode 9
ending explained or Avatar 2 trailer
breakdown with that out of the way
thanks for your constant support I've
been Jared and these Jammy Dodges are
bang up anyway I'll see you in the next
one take care and peace